this program is brought to you by Emory
University
we've gone a long time I guess thinking
about trends and beginning AIDS was
simply neglected and denied before we
realized how big the problem was it was
really only a handful of people getting
sick and dying in a few big cities but
when the virus was discovered it became
clear that this was a very widespread
infection that was going to have
widespread implications fear then became
that it was spread through casual
contact which we now know it wasn't but
that led to a lot of the panic and
ignoring of people so we went from
denial on one hand and in ignorance and
neglect to fear and panic as we do with
many infectious diseases and fortunately
we went from ignorance to enlightenment
when people started to understand how
its transmission and how important it
was the preceding program is copyrighted
by Emory University